a minister announced today that the
government does intend to break
international law will you be talking to
conservative mps
about trying to amend this bill is there
a rebellion on the way
well what the government's proposing is
wrong i think that's
plain for everybody to see but we need
to step back here and focus
on getting a deal getting a deal is in
the national interest
but in terms of the internal market bill
are you talking
to conservative mps about mounting a
rebellion to try and amend this
legislation you
as a lawyer must be concerned that the
government intends to break
international law getting a deal is in
the national interest that's what the
public want that's what they were
promised the outstanding issues are not
difficult they can be resolved
let's get the deal let's move on and
focus on the job in hand which is
dealing with this pandemic so do you
think that this is all a distraction the
withdrawal agreement
there's certainly a case to be made that
this is all just being used for leverage
in the
uh negotiations and that's wrong in
principle so you think he's bluffing
well look i think what the nation wants
is a deal
that is in the national interest and
everything should be focused on that
let's not reopen old arguments that the
public think are long
settled and that's what the government's
doing here okay jeremy corbyn was
criticized in the election
for failing to take a clear position on
brexit and it hurt labour clearly
your leader now what is your position is
brexit a good idea
or is it now just a question of damage
limitation
we have left the eu and therefore the
arguments about leave and remain that
have torn us apart for
the last few years are over and i'm very
clear therefore what's now in the
national interest
is getting a deal i want a deal that
allows businesses to thrive
for people to have good job
opportunities and to preserve peace in
northern ireland so we've left the eu
the divide between leave and remain
is over we need a deal a deal is in the
national okay just before we get on to
that just to be clear then
could you ever see us rejoining the eu
would you ever make that argument or do
you now
think that this is a matter that has
been settled for a generation
look i don't think there's a case for
reopening the issue of membership of the
eu we have left a deal can be struck in
the next few weeks the issues that are
outstanding are not insurmountable
to have no deal would be a failure of
negotiation a failure has to be owned by
the prime minister
he promised the british people he'd get
a good deal he needs to deliver on that
promise
well you you've been very critical of
him and you're critical now
what have you actually done since being
labour leader to
try and influence the outcome of
negotiations because to my mind
you've barely said anything at all or
tried to influence it in any way in fact
you've tried to avoid the question
well the prime minister won the election
it was a devastating election
for the labour party he won by promising
he would get a good deal so what i've
said is
uh here's the space get that good deal
deliver on your promise and that's what
i've been saying for the last few weeks
and months
is what i say today i think a good deal
is there to be had
the prime minister needs to get on and
negotiate it and just quickly what
specifically when you say a good deal
what are the specific elements that you
would like to see in that deal
i think the most important thing and
this comes from businesses across the uk
it is a deal that allows them to thrive
in the future
that allows people to have good jobs um
and of course preserves peace in
northern ireland they're the three
elements i think that matter more than
anything
okay and just quickly jonathan jones um
you
probably personally know him given that
you have a background in the legal
profession were you surprised at his
resignation what did you make of it
well jonathan is a first-class lawyer
who's given excellent advice
uh over the years and i'm absolutely
sure he would not have done this lightly
have you spoken to him i haven't spoken
to him but i've known him many years
did it give you cause for concern in
that if he felt that he couldn't
continue in government
that there was a serious issue regarding
international law here
well as i say he's a first-class lawyer
and he would not have done this lightly
and just finally on brexit um a senior
government figure said to me yesterday
that they thought there was 30
chance now of a deal where would you put
the chances of a trade deal at
i think a trade deal can be struck i
think
that the outstanding issues are capable
of being resolved
and i think the government needs to get
on in the negotiations resolve the
difficulties
and deliver the deal they promise the
british public and is there anything
impractical terms you can do to help
facilitate
that such as talking to the eu leaders
yourself well i don't think
at this stage the government is going to
involve me in talking to the
eu but i think it's straightforward get
on with the negotiations resolve those
outstanding
issues deliver on the promises you made
the deals in the national interest
let's get that deal move on concentrate
on the job in hand which is defeating
the virus